rein mathematisch gesehen und auf den
ein steinigen gleichungen basierend
müsste es nicht nur schwarze sondern
auch sogenannte weiße löcher geben
vereinfacht gesagt das komplette
gegenteil von schwarzen löchern
nichts kann in das weiße loch gelangen
strahlung und materie können nur
abgegeben werden nichts führt in die
andere richtung doch bisher konnten
astronomen astronomen solche objekte
noch nie beobachten wie genau kann man
sich also weiße löcher vorstellen und
was haben sie mit bohrlöchern zu tun hat
sich willkommen bei klick zum fixen hier
gibt es täglich science videos mit
extrem spannenden themen abonniert den
kanal nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's ja und vielen dank für diesen
coolen themenvorschlag der aus eurer
whatsapp community kam albert einsteins
allgemeine relativitätstheorie hat
schwarze löcher als direktes ergebnis
denn seine gleichungen beschreiben wie
sich raumzeit in anwesenheit von massen
verhält vereinfacht gesagt wird die
raumzeit extrem stark gekrümmt sobald
sich viel masse auf wenig raum
konzentriert nichts kann dann mehr aus
der nähe dieser massen kommen alles muss
dort hinter diesem sogenannten
ereignishorizont bleiben selbst licht
eine längere zeit dachte man dass diese
mathematischen lösungen nur theoretisch
sein
selbst ein stein hielt schwarze löcher
für unmöglich bis dann schwarze löcher
tatsächlich entdeckt wurden
beispielsweise wenn sie aus dem kollaps
normaler sterne entstanden sind
einsteins gleichung lassen aber auch
noch andere lösungen zu und das sind die
der weißen durch weiße löcher sind also
mathematisch gesehen absolut gültige
lösungen der einsteinschen gleichung
doch was heißt das konkret
auch ein weißes loch hat einen
ereignishorizont allerdings genau
gegenteilig zudem des schwarzen loches
es verschluckt materie und strahlung und
gibt nichts davon wieder ab als eine
umkehrung des schwarzen loches hat es
die eigenschaft dass strahlung materie
ständig herausfließen würden nichts
davon könnte in sein inneres gelangen
schon seit längerer zeit beschäftigen
sich forschungsteams weltweit auch mit
weißem löchern doch bisher blieben sie
immer im schatten ihrer großen brüder
den schwarzen löchern 2014 gab es
beispielsweise eine arbeit zu dem thema
demnach könnte ein weißes loch aus einem
schwarzen loch entstehen und zwar durch
einen so genannten quanten bauens
quantengravitation effekte würden
demnach dafür sorgen dass ein schwarzes
loch kurz nach seiner entstehung in sich
zusammenfällt und quasi zurückprallte
durch diesen konten bauens entstünde
dann aus dem schwarzen ein weißes loch
das explodiert und verschwindet ähnlich
wie bei einer supernova die arbeit der
beiden us physiker ist in fachkreisen
allerdings umstritten
doch gibt es auch spekulationen die
beiden phänomene also schwarze und weiße
löcher kombinieren denn der allgemeinen
relativitätstheorie zufolge ist es
möglich raum zeiten aneinander zu kleben
man kann also theoretisch ein system aus
einem weißen und einem schwarzen loch
bauen das wird in der theoretischen
physik dann wurmloch oder auch einstein
rosen brücke genannt und das wäre
tatsächlich sehr abenteuerlich denn es
würde auf der einen seite der raumzeit
strahlung und materie verschlucken dann
durch einen raum zeit kanal
transportieren und auf der anderen seite
wieder ausstoßen
ein kanal quasi zwischen universen oder
flachen raum zeiten doch so
erstrebenswert wäre eine solche reise
durch das noch gar nicht enorme kräfte
würden alles zerreißen und zerquetschen
wenn man den theoretischen berechnungen
glauben schenken kann wäre der kanal
auch nur sehr kurz stabil und würde dann
wieder verschwinden wenn wir menschen
eine reise durch ein solches wurmloch
wagen würden wäre dies eine reise ins
ungewisse und extrem wahrscheinlich in
den tod
bisher lief die fahndung nach weißen
löchern aber auch ergebnislos kein
bislang beobachtete objekt machte den
anschein als würde es sich um ein weißes
loch handeln dabei sollten sie viel
deutlicher zu erkennen sein als ihre
dunklen verwandten aber vielleicht auch
eben nur für einen sekundenbruchteil und
natürlich muss nicht jede mathematische
lösung auch eine reale entsprechung
haben heißt also konkret obwohl sie
keinen widerspruch zur
relativitätstheorie darstellen muss es
sie nicht unbedingt auch in echt geben
auf der anderen seite hat man wie gesagt
auch bei schwarzen löchern lange an
ihrer existenz gezweifelt und auch erst
deutlich später festgestellt dass sie
nicht nur auf dem platz sondern auch in
der realität gibt was jedoch dagegen
spricht bislang ist uns kein mechanismus
bekannt durch den 1
das loch entstehen könnte zudem gibt es
auch einen widerspruch zum zweiten
hauptsatz der thermodynamik nach der die
entropie im universum nur gleich bleiben
kann oder aber abnimmt dennoch komplett
ausgeschlossen ist die existenz von
weißen löchern auf keinen fall denn wenn
wir ehrlich sind sind wir noch gar nicht
umfassend in der lage extreme zustände
wie in einem schwarzen oder weißen loch
zu beschreiben hierzu müsste man
zunächst einmal das puzzlestück zwischen
gravitation und quantenmechanik finden
und eine theorie aufstellen in der wir
beide vereinen können spätestens dann
würden wir sicherlich auch neue
erkenntnisse über weiße löcher bekommen
wenn es die gibt dann erfahrt ihr es
hier natürlich zuerst bleibt also klicks
zum teuersten bis dann bleibt dran